We begin with a definition.
A flow network consists of,
among other things, a directed graph, G,
and we will disallow anti-parallel
edges to simplify some of the equation.
This is not a serious limitation,
as we'll see.
We'll distinguish to special
vertices in the graph.
A source, typically labeled s.
This is where whatever is flowing
to the network starts from.
And a sync typically labeled t,
this is where the flow ends up.
We call all other vertices internal.
To keep our equations a little simpler,
we'll assume there are no incoming
edges into s, or outgoing edges from t.
Associated with every pair of vertices
is a capacity which indicates
how much flow it is possible to
send directly between two vertices.
We will assume that these capacity's
are always non negative integers.
This will make some of the arguments
easier and it's not a serious limitation
in fact the last algorithm
we see will overcome it.
Also note that if there
is no edge in the graph,
then the capacity is defined to be 0.
That's the flow network,
the flow itself is a function from pairs
of vertices to the non negative reels.
Clearly then, it must be non negative,
and it can't exceed the capacity for
any pair of vertices.
Also we require that between any two
vertices, at least one direction be 0.
And it doesn't make sense to have flow
going from one vertex to another,
only to send it back again.
Lastly, we require that flow be
conserved at every internal vertex.
We define, f in, to be the flow, into
a vertex, and f out, to be the flow out.
And we require that the two be equal.
So for example, in this node here,
I have 4 plus 2 coming in, and
I have 5 plus 1 going out.
These are both 6, so we say that
flow is conserved at this vertex.
Intuitively, this just means that
internal nodes can't generate or
absorb any of the stuff that's flowing.
Those are the jobs of the source,
and of the sync.
The overall value of the flow,
is defined as the flow going
out of the source, or equivalently,
the flow going into the sync.